hello guys
[Music]
hello hello wow
this is jasmine and amy's morning show
live from niranga
island say hi amy
hi guys it's the queen's stream
the queens are here we got the chick in
the back
see the chicken over there she's called
ava
is she a nice one or yeah no she's great
i like
we like
making sure so
um hello guys first of all just want to
say
thank you so much to everyone who
chipped in to get me
the a amazing capture card
for my birthday we're freaking using it
now
and look how good it is it's so good
that's a really that's a really good
note i don't have that much
[Music]
um guys just so you know today we're
going to give you the premise
we are going to do a bunch of different
things with you we're going to show you
around my island
we're going to do a q a with you using
that little
what is that called turn wheel wheel
turning turn wheel
okay great
and um there's going to be some music
we've got a special music insert as well
um from someone called luke
so that will be interesting and
the best bit that i haven't even
explained yet is
that you guys can come to the island i
have a dodo code
my gates are open so we're gonna wait
for people to arrive
and i'm giving out the dodo code in the
chat right now
so please come and join us and uh
just have fun with us throughout
this little animal crossing morning
stream
[Music]
yep
if you have a princess outfit please
come at it because
i think we look amazing today yes if you
want to dress up as queens for the green
stream
then do it also thank you so much for
following
mackie lucky and jan dress
or jay andres 4 30
really appreciate that i said i spent a
lot of time
setting up this little podcast there i'm
very proud of it
this is uh this is our announcement
stage
uh this is our cozy cozy silver bit
and uh annoyingly it looks better at
night
because because obviously it's got the
um
the spotlight and stuff but this is the
cake that my mom got me
oh my mom got me the same cake how cute
what
were your moms thinking i don't know
unless we have the same number
what what do you look at
[Music]
oh no it's stick i must pick it up it's
gross get away
um oh i also i did this
so if while we're doing the podcast
people can come and like sit behind
us the chicken was walking around here
earlier and i was really hoping she
would sit
down they they've been playing with my
musical instruments and it's [ __ ]
great yeah i put these here
so while we're talking people could be
in the background
[Music]
um
[Music]
apparently the voices are low so i'm
going to turn the game down
and make sure that we're up
guys if you just let let us know i've
turned the game down now so let me know
if you need me to change anything else
ah thank you so much stream door for the
tip really appreciate that
it's amazing oh that's so sweet thank
you for making your day's a bit brighter
every time you stream once more happy
birthday
ah i was talking to amy about this
yesterday about all the lovely messages
i've been getting and just like how
crazy it is
it makes you so happy it's good
it's good it's good it's good and then
we were talking about how the
development of
i i perfectly positioned these chairs so
you could just get through them look
oh wow
[Laughter]
um the thing is i can't actually hear
the game
at all so uh you're just gonna have to
tell me how
yeah i don't want to go too far once you
get into
here though you can just go this way so
this is my airport right around here
and then uh just uh you know the only
rule
of the day really don't be shy i think
that
can relate to different situations yeah
just don't be shy
and then you come over here and this is
where we'll be
by the squirting piece of sand
my friend denise got me the ukulele and
the birds that's singing bread for my
birthday
yeah whoa we have
someone coming the chat wants to know
where's brayden though
sleeping probably he doesn't really get
up
until like after midday
the internet wallflower is on his way
ew from iris island
yes
[Music]
yes says to all the onions out there
don't be shy to freedom
nikki likes don't be shy love the
warning williams
it's a straightforward warning yeah just
don't be shy please
uh i have a secret hidden around my
island as well
have you told me about the secret um
maybe no i don't think i have oh
he's wearing the cactus jumper
so for you guys that don't know um the
cactus jumper is one of my animal
crossing designs that's so
cute yay luke let's go and see luke
[Music]
[Music]
someone else is coming what we got more
people
oh we might have stand-up clothes and
they have gates
and literally two people whoa so popular
what never had so many friends before
oh i don't even know who this is cherry
from cherry island
a tropically grown sort of cherry oh
i'm so excited
they're like amy it won't be a secret
anymore patience
yeah i don't have patience
don't know if you guys can tell yeah so
joanne dole this animation plays every
time someone new comes to the island
that's why i'm thinking i'm gonna close
the gates once everyone comes in
so we can have the show without having
interruptions like this i think that is
probably the best thing to do
[Music]
oh i love cherry's dress oh my god
cherry
you are a princess you're an angel or
you look like an
actual rose yes
oh my god i love it
wow two people
two friends this is so exciting
oh my god
i feel like we need to move this don't
give me enough room for people
who it is all gonna be like stuck
on the little platform bit where you
come in
this is so exciting so
exciting who is cherry who is cherry
maria oh maria pizza
oh were you just guessing well
it says maria oh
this one i thought you meant cherry very
fresh for innovator maria
is that is this maria pizza
i'm guessing it might be
if one said like heathrow airport
so what did you say oh marion
hi sorry for butchering your name thank
you so much for coming to the island
this is exciting
oh she's yeah i think i think it is
maria pizza she's new in animal crossing
well good there's um hopefully i won't
hopefully hopefully no spoilers is it
spoilers week
nah i'll be fine you'll just see what's
to come
see what the future holds oh my god i
love her
yes me too
oh so many people i'm so excited i
literally thought there was
no one am i here friends
should we try and move back to the
podcast please
oh but what if more people come and then
they don't know where to go
this way oh wait wait wait oh
wait look i can type
hi hi cherry oh
thank you for coming thank you
oh my god lucas
oh my god i love it so
much luke is such a
pretty person luke is goals
right now ah
so cute i love it
oh my god look at everyone look at us
oh cram flakes
yeah look at us all with our tiaras and
maria's cool
hat that is a cool hat maroon
okay should we should we certainly make
our way back to the um
uh to the podcast area i'll put the dodo
code out once more we'll see if anyone
else is coming
um is anyone else if anyone else is
coming let us know in the chat and we'll
wait for you
if not i might close the gate soon you
guys are good enough
love you guys
[Music]
oh my god i'm just like it's just so
funny
luke's supposed to be working but
instead he's prancing around my island
with a dress
he's living his best life we've got a
new person
this is so exciting
is this something like because they said
they were coming sorry guys i keep
screaming i scream every single stream
doesn't matter if i'm playing horror
game or not
i agree with mantas luke isn't that
[Laughter]
a communication error what do you mean
what does that mean
does that mean everyone just got boot
did
don't say everyone
no i'm so sorry guys i'll get another
one
one second
no
[Music]
do you need a new code now
yeah i have to get another code because
like i don't know why that happened then
you want them we'll just wait we'll wait
for people to come in
[Music]
surely this should be okay
we'll try and wait for at least the same
amount of people to come in and someone
out of it because i know he's trying to
get in
yeah hey lucio you want to play animal
crossing
get animal crossing and you can play
with us
[Music]
oh i hate this it goes on forever i i
want everything
i want everything
[Music]
that's my dodo code f
six seven n one
dodo code
all right let me see apologies about the
technical difficulties there's been a
lot of them today
right not as many as like previous
streams i feel like
that's true i feel like my knowledge of
streaming is slowly getting better
i'm like stream master almost
is that you amy i'm hoping so
i don't know i'm trying because i'm
getting ready to depart
now i wonder like what's gonna happen if
everyone comes at the same time
it's like the game's gonna explode this
is lick
ah i can't come
probably because luke's coming so you'll
have to wait yeah sorry guys there's a
queue
that's okay i'll go after luke
q for the well esteemed
narangha islands
we appreciate your patience
[Music]
it's a very popular
tourist destination
ah cool he's just one-upped his outfit
with some shades
oh yes
why does he keep just getting cooler
hey valentine's scam thank you for
following i don't know he just keeps
like one-upping everyone
look look i mean i know my birthday was
yesterday but still technically my
birthday can you not show me up please
thanks okay i'm on my way guys
a rascally ghost is mine still like a
over tired try harder what was mine
i think it was overtired no something
else it was something funnier than that
like i know before it was like um
what was it like esteemed trash or like
something trash
defined trash well-defined trash i think
that was my
last one
oh i can't wait for you to see my
outfits
yes i have a few too hey jamie
wait someone lanavik said someone
olympic said it might have been his
fault maybe not just try again i mean
like unless
you're using just the switch and you
know you're not using any like
weird illegal hacky stuff right
wow there's just an influx of people
coming right now i'm just gonna i'm just
gonna
sit back and relax on my little fish
wand
oh okay this is you
wait no you i'm lordy yeah i'm here so
someone else
who would probably be who could it be
i can't wait to just walk you guys
around my island
oh it's terry sherry jerry got back
in thank you back for coming wait that
doesn't make sense
thank you for coming back
[Music]
ah thanks dude um draendor just uh
gave the new code to
the uh to the discord
yes more friends please
yes oh no
someone else is always faster than uh
thank you so much for this year you're
you're a stream
senses not a master yet if you update
your donors then you'll be a master
oh my gosh yes i i i
if you ever want any of this back just
please just let me i know i keep saying
that but i'm just like wow
i cannot believe just like how generous
you've been this weekend
thank you
oh let's see if i can get any closer to
the podcast
cherry and berry are you reunited cherry
and berry
amy it's you you and jerry
me and cherry was meant to be
what's on that way
i like when alicia tips there was like a
little gift so
i'm not a well esteemed
oh it's maria maria's back okay
so we've got we've got all our og's we
got our original
islanders and now if someone out of it
comes
and it crashes again i'm coming like
that you're banned
[Laughter]
wow i know i have i hope he makes it in
am
i i don't know she's a harsh queen
i just got to do what's best for the
people you know
[Music]
i wish it played this song when i was on
a plane
i'll take all my money back sure
i'm so come i'm so conflicted what does
that mean
do you actually though
don't mess with me like this
oh she's upgraded her coat oh
that's nice she's looking fancy
okay someone anime is this you
is this you i like everyone's just like
filtering through i wonder if they were
just waiting at the end of the dialogue
that's what i did i because you can ask
them to try again
if it won't let you oh okay yeah
probably them that's probably why
they're just like filtering through
right now
i'm actually scared i know everyone
crossed your face
is he gonna make it in oh it's wrong
it's out it's elvis
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
you can do it we believe in you thanks
for coming though elvis
i'm looking forward to seeing what you
look like actually
i hope it's fabulous i hope it's
fabulous as well
we need two fab lads i mean astronaut
works
too yes i love it
space helmet for the win
face queen space queen
we're all queens here okay someone else
oh geez
[Music]
what is this it's just like hours of
just this like
such a big queue to get to narango
island
how long has it been can't wait to get
to that island where all you do is just
sit and wait for other people to come to
the island
it's so good like
[Music]
there's no point trying to do anything
in between
oh my god hey tom we're still just
waiting for people to come to the island
it crashed once
but the capture card is it's working out
splendidly
who's this is the zombie anime don't
even know how to pronounce
jelfy joffee are you in the chat
joey make yourself known say hello
[Music]
why would i keep donating big donuts if
i wanted it back of course i'm giving it
to you no need to give it back there's
pocket change in my pockets
well thank you alicia okay i'll take oh
i'll stop i'll stop being stupid now
thank you
thank you thank you like all i can say
is
thank you oh my god i
i will buy myself like some really nice
coffee
and then it will give me more energy for
these streams
we got a player up in here
[Music]
not the most subtle of flex yeah
okay so i'm a lot of egg i can move
should i close the gates i don't want to
because i want you to make it come on
where are you zom zom do this
zom invade his arm
i really want this coffee that you have
here it's like look it's like when you
fart oh never mind
someone's coming is it is it zom
i hope so
tom's like get over there zom go on you
can do it
[Laughter]
oh my god
i really don't want to be kicked off
again please
make it oh my god
i'm holding my breath i don't know why
no two is bad luck
it didn't get this far before milo milo
but thank you milo and you're an older
brother that's real cute
a responsible little brother right there
you know what i always wanted an older
brother so this could be like
my day you know all my dreams come true
to get more friends than i could have
ever imagined
be on an island you know not at my house
yeah this day is good one already
arriving from out of heaven wow this
person sounds
extremely angelic so it's haven
i was a haven
i don't know what that looks like
[Music]
oh you're wearing my jumper as well
and your hair is [ __ ] wow it reminds
me of that dude from resident evil 3
remake
oh my god i should just make a video
where like
yagma rates animal crossing
outfits okay zoma we still waiting for
you or have you given up
wait that is him that's him
close the gate close the car should i
close the gate
is anyone else coming let me know in the
chat right now you have 10 seconds
oh well 20 because of the lag 20
19 18 17 16
15 14 13 12
11 10 9 eight
seven six five four
three three two one
she's closing the gates i'm closing the
gates
i'm closing the gate the gates are now
closed
and no one can come in and
cool that's it
great
okay
[Laughter]
oh my god i'm so happy
luke that's not where you should be
standing love get off that that's for me
and amy
[Laughter]
i'm joking you can come back up i feel
bad now
[Laughter]
so guys there are some musical
instruments behind here feel free to
play the drums play the ukulele do
whatever the hell you want
you know tambourine queen my island is
your island
let's all have some fun
oh my god wait guys everyone come wait
what's this
a present i'll leave it here we're gonna
open presents after we do the island
tour so if anyone has presents
leave them here i'll open them when we
get back thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you that's
adorable
what what is presents that's so cute
oh yes thank you
okay this dude right here i don't know
if you can see
he is my favorite he's called bill and
he's my favorite
but apparently he's also a girl
she
so they they
birthday they were playing with these
close friends how cute is the ukulele
my friend denise got me the ukulele and
i was like
i love it
okay what are we doing now well
i i've already seen you got i got what
maria's talking to bill yeah yeah
everyone on phil bill's the best bill's
best
do you like his little headpiece i got
him a headpiece
is it the easter one oh my god the
easter one yeah but bill looks cute in
it because everything's not real
i actually have an outfit that would be
cute with me and bill
yeah but i don't know if we're doing
outfits just yet
okay i am going to um
i'm going to wear an outfit so we can go
and explore what one should i wear
all right everyone follow the superhero
okay i'm coming milo's confused
okay guys uh you can you can do whatever
you want you don't have to follow me
oh my god that's so cute that's the
cutest
the cutest outfit um
uh excuse me elvis no hitting the
birthday girl
don't be shy don't be shy everybody do
not be
shy
don't be shy don't be shy don't be shy
wait i thought you were doing the island
tour oh yeah no this is the island tour
all right follow me this way why is he
here
because it's saturday oh my god it's
saturday
[Laughter]
it's kkk it's our dude oh no it's monday
it's monday wait wait i have an outfit
that goes with this
look look look look okay
and then look at me wait one sec wait
how do i do this again
i'm a slush oh puppy
i love it
so uh this is up here is my
playground
[Music]
oh my god wait who is this who is the
skeleton
this is me hello oh my god because look
same nice yeah you don't have any shoes
on
no because skeletons don't wear shoes oh
my skeleton does wear shoes
i do actually have the same socks on
under these issues
oh my god i love it i've also got it i
love this one
oh my gosh it's called sushi trash
i'm a wizard skating tennis
so if anyone wants to buy any outfits
feel free into the edible sisters
and i see some of you already have this
wonderful attire
made by zee why am i talking like this
made by yagnanix
um i don't know what they have today i
haven't even been in here yet
so i'm gonna go in once elvis
finds the door handle yeah great oh it's
like oh my god i love that outfit
oh my god who is that that is amazing
cherry
are we all going in here i'm confused
[Music]
oh you can come in if you want
yeah and then yeah
yeah oh nick's wearing my salad fingers
hat
i i still think there's more i need to
do on that hat but i'm glad you like it
it's got little eyes oh that's cute
yeah if anyone wants to take my jumpers
or my salad fingers hat
is this a face mask thank you alyssia
like and subscribe and you'll magically
receive a nintendo switch with a copy of
animal crossing tour with you
will you i'm not i'm not going to i'm
not
i'm not i did just say that but it
didn't mean that okay there's a
difference between saying and meaning
wow there's so much stuff going on
look at so many we have so many friends
what
[Music]
all right i'll wait for you guys outside
yeah
bye lucas i'll wait for you in the so
this is the parents bit like where
parents sit and like wait for their kids
who are playing in the park oh here
yeah there's snacks they have some
snacks
and they just wait for the kids hey
elvis
look oh wait okay
strawberry i'm a strawberry and i'm a
kiwi sushi
it's so cute
that's why the keyword is magically said
alicia
okay okay that makes sense
i like that shirt wait what one
um is everyone here
is everyone here oh no no no maria
maria is wearing you're wearing the
colors of narang her
land i just want you to know maria
i kind of can't get to her
oh my god wait where are we going now uh
right okay this is so fun
um so if you would like to
um i mean we
there's really nothing oh god i'm stuck
um so we go over here i mean this is my
museum
i i need to get bridge here eventually
but uh at the moment i don't have one
but it's on its own little island it's a
it looks
cooler
you can you can jump over
oh yeah so talk game design
right i've started to put the paths in
my island but i don't like paths
so i'm doing these circles but then
every time there was a point of interest
or a shop
or at an intersection i put the rocks in
so that's how i've got my visual schemes
this is my level design
of the animal crossing island do you
like it
yes i do i also don't like puffs
that much so i've got my own way of
doing it the past which
i'm showing you thank you i told my
friend that and then
every time he saw rocks he was like
point the pinterest point of intro
yes point of interest anyone would
would anyone like coffee oh please i
actually like it
there you go yeah we do actually mine's
no we're done we'll have a little break
after the island tour
luke wants coffee i like coffee
uh does anyone want to buy anything from
the shop
i'll go in anyway of course we can all
go in
one at a time or delete you
there are two doors but only one person
may enter
wait what oh there you are
they're not usually apart like this oh
what's your turn at prices oh yeah
turnip prices i don't know i haven't
played today yet
so you you guys can go and oh wait i'm
already inside i could go and ask for
you what am i doing
michael castilla thank you so much for
the super chat did you say anything
though
it didn't pop up yet
okay so my turn at prices guys uh 125
bells that's not too bad it's not too
[Music]
good
[Music]
so 125 that's what it is if you guys
want to
then grab yourself one of them
oh yeah i've still got the presents that
you gave me in the mail
i think we should play a game later
because i've got stuff that i could give
to
some of you guys but i don't have enough
to give it to all of you so i feel kind
of bad
wait how many of us are there not
including me and you
one two three four three four
four no there's others outside
let's go
[Music]
no that's a coffee mug
wait my one
this is my outfit that i curated just
for today oh that's so cute
i've got a birthday outfit kind of like
that this island is pretty thank you
it's very it's still very um
i know it's very basic simple
humble humble oh i like these
i don't have these i do not yeah they're
nice
okay um i think it's time for an outfit
change
uh and then we can continue
oh god you guys are gonna love this
yeah oh my god you look like jordan
i'm an emo kid non-conforming as can be
you'd be non-conforming too if you look
just like me i have hair
my nails and makeup on my face
but more punk with this hairstyle
oh guys look i got a cool koala
look don't we look don't we look cool
together wait where did you go
up here
here i'm on the beach
oh wait come find me here means hear me
i'm on the beach just walk up the beach
hello
oh look luke's gone all rocky as well
wow
i love your hat did you design that hat
because that's cool i've had
wait where have you guys gone oh they've
all gone down there because i've got
cookies
oh
who's with the poppers i love them i
just see them every now and then just
going off
yeah oh you did design that hat there's
a cool-ass hat
okay guys are you okay amy
yeah sorry i was in technical
difficulties at home
cool don't worry me too all the time um
so this is gonna be my back
like um it's a background to the shop i
want it to be like a man-made
pond because i realized i didn't really
have many ponds
so i need to put some fencing around it
and this is where like you can just sit
and fish and just have some fun
nice little fish friend here
uh oh does anyone want the fossil
i haven't haven't played today this is
from your island amy i don't want him
yeah i don't he left for a reason
uh alyssa you guys play hide and seek
maybe we can play hide and seek
later yeah we could do that later
yeah we'll do that later because we do
have stuff planned so
we can do that later though definitely
this is going to go on for a little
while i think
this live stream
may i steal the apple take take the
fruit take the fruit
it's totally cool they all grow back
apple addictive the only thing is i just
don't take the petals of the flowers
that i really like
i can oh take my roses
which ones do you really like michael's
like oh
can uh this ones basically like on the
floor i'll tell you which ones because
they're the ones that i don't have very
many of
but the roses yeah
[Music]
i think i pitched a bunch of roses the
first time i came
um
should we take you up there yeah go on
then
okay let's go up here oh luke's already
up there you know
um so this is
very much still in development i want to
have like a zen
tent and stuff up here so like either a
rock
concert thing happening or like
somewhere where you can like get away
from the world
this is my pool area so you can like
have a little swim swim swim swim swim
and uh yeah you guys have already found
the camping area i quite like this area
oh this tarantula does i have yeah i got
the tarantula
come on
it won't let me jump it will it just
takes a while
yes and this whole little area up here
is
this is cool
um
i'll show you one more thing up here
so this is my secret garden
and if you could nobody use ladders
here because you're not supposed to
it's a secret garden down here and it's
hidden
when you say down here they're ready oh
i see
see it's where all my money trees are
but like
i need to put more stuff in so that you
can't use your ladder because i don't
want people to use their ladders
but still your money you might be able
to tell where the entrance is but it's
quite hidden
so it's like a little secret money
garden and every time i find a tree i
put it in there like a money tree
so if you want to um you can fight
amongst yourselves
and go grab that cash if you want it i
mean maria did say she's new
so if anyone's gonna have it
but maybe maybe maria but i'm stuck
if you can find the entrance you can you
can get the money that's all i'm saying
if you could find the entrance actually
no no one uses that to say okay
you're so obedient i love it i'm gonna
wait here
can you guys see if you can find the
entrance and i'll just wait here
oh i definitely will okay go go
go me and luke are like racing
go find the entrance guys hey excited
about the day
they found it
um can someone give that some money to
maria though she's just started the game
maria get the money maria go find the
entrance
wait i need to cut for you guys well
done finding the edge reds
you're all geniuses
i'll show i'll show these guys they're
like no i can't
i can't come on guys it's okay we got
this
for maria i'll show you guys just follow
me
oh wait maria is talking
i'm confused i have confusion it's okay
maria just come follow me
it looks like stealing its bags but it's
not stealing if i told you it was okay
okay and then this way guys
you see do we still have maria oh yeah
they
okay and then we go up here
[Music]
excuse me and then in here
and this is the secret entrance
it's quite cool though isn't it like
there's not much you can do
secret wise are you still there amy
[Music]
uh
can't amy you
amy i'm still on the call with you
are you there amy's gone
[Music]
okay guys you can take the cash take the
cash
oh yeah roses steal all the roses take
all the rooms
stick on the road steal all the cash
take on the roses drinking my [ __ ]
97 000 bells jesus christ that's a lot
of bells
take it it's yours
[Music]
but where's amy amy
i'm gonna disconnect to the inferno
again wait yeah did someone give me the
emails or they oh you're back
yeah i think my headphones i don't know
i don't know what happened okay well
you're back that's the main thing
yeah oh someone left oh someone left no
you didn't we didn't finish the tour
it's okay everyone's saying r.i.p
to me i know because you just like
randomly went quiet and i was like amy
are you are you there
i was very confused because i was just
having a conversation with myself and
then i was like
yeah yes
i think we have to watch them leave now
don't we
i think so
oh no elvis got kicked
wait did you actually mean you got
kicked or like
you just because i don't can you kick
people if you're not like
the island resident i don't
can you i mean this is still the gift to
give
okay wait uh are you guys still by the
trees and stuff
wait are you guys awesome now
oh my god you're all here now okay wait
let me
should i try and open it again wait no
elvis you're here
well not really i just oh i remember
outfit what just happened
elvis is here i don't know
that's elvis
wait i think i think we have everyone
don't we okay wait maria yet
yeah we have everyone we are did anyone
okay that's really weird um i feel
i'm not forgetting it i am confusion
okay we'll go back to where we were did
everyone get the bells that i offered
you guys
oh my god maria get the bells get the
wheels
get the bells get the bells get the
bells get the bills
yes you need to get your presents oh
yeah i'll get the present
maria you get the bells oh thank you
present uh where is it
we're gonna get the bails where will
[Music]
maria
ah okay if you don't want to that's fine
uh that's totally fine but if anyone
decides they do want to take some vowels
from my trees
or the one that like luke dropped or
something
then you know where they are you know
where my secret garden is
luke says it's not fine it's not mine
don't listen to yours
i can't force her to take your money why
is this
take his money maria do it
sign your life away for 91
bells it's a 91 97
bell
honestly it's totally cool he is giving
them to you he wants
he wants you to have it okay
i don't think that's gonna happen yeah
okay that's cool
we get it you're a very lovely person
okay let's go let's carry on with the
tour does anyone need the toilet
isn't that like
i like this basket thanks
sassy [ __ ]
milo i'm gonna block you what why
why what
[Music]
oh no uh okay actually not up here sorry
i mean where did we go
okay for this
let me think we'll get we'll go back
let's go back to um
to my airport
and i'll show you the
oh no not this houses
[Music]
oh no wait wait what about cherry
cherry no
very interesting thank you for coming
cherry
okay so uh yes it looks like
yummy no jerry
okay so this is my little my little town
where my little
my little residents reside
um i quite like it it's like a little
built-up
area and then i've got my lighthouse
here
you know the lighthouse that everybody
needs
if i don't need to like house i need to
get this rid of this tree because it
it's blocking the entrance you can't see
where the entrance is
oh yeah sweet i like it
and um we've got you know i
i uh catered for for all types
of animals
uh i'm i'm saving up for a bridge so
sorry
um this is this this is a stick
you need a stick this is a stick
so to get over here you'll need a stick
do you guys have sticks
[Music]
i can give you a stick
[Music]
i got my stick oh wait do you reckon
maria have you got a stick yet because
there is a long way to get over here i
can show you how
if you need it
oh yeah
before he gets to what he needs
i can make more money so this is um
this is the island uh god
and we need to give him sacrifices to
keep the god happy
oh thank god and you give you this
you give it to the turtle or the
tortoise staffing turtle
and you do the gong you wake him up and
uh he decides whether he likes your
offering or not
if he doesn't like it then you might get
eaten but you know
a turtle yeah touch it maria it bites
yeah you are touch it if i
touch it bites
what is your god called you named him
no no no no he's not he's not a pet
he's god oh he's just god with the
capital
offer presents here i mean if you want
to there's
the last person that came gave peaches i
don't think peaches are a good offering
oh they're everywhere look at them
they're here
wait are there any fruits that you lose
uh pears actually yeah i should have
brought you pears
that's okay i kind of like like
looking for them myself and it's the
last thing
oh okay thanks luke wait is this for the
god
is this for god
i'll leave i'll leave it here for him
hopefully he is satisfied wait
luke you got to do the bomb
so that he knows that the present is
from you
[Music]
so that if he doesn't like it he eats
you and not me
dude
luke do the gong
look he's just like laugh i didn't give
a prank
wait who did zom was it you
i'm confusion who put this here
the turtle did it oh my god
that turtle did it
okay cool all right if we go over this
way now
fellas that's away
[Music]
to the right to the right the island
uh this is my flower bed
this is my house
but also you've got to be careful
because there's a lot of um there's a
lot of creatures around
no the loch ness monster
i love that sign it's cute eh
yeah where you can go on the lookout for
the loch ness monster it's right behind
my house
i love it awesome i think zomlanovic was
watering my plants
that's so cute okay so i'm lying what's
going in my house so i guess we're going
in here now
we're going in the house
luke thinks he's he'll be fired is that
because he's
playing on this you don't have to save
if you can't stay luke
if you don't mind just like don't leave
until the end of this like you can just
like put the game down or whatever
uh this is my house oh you've got so
many pets
rave
yeah it's very humble because i've been
spending most of my money
trying to get my i moved pretty much all
the houses
okay cool tea set
thank you very much
thank you and then my i think my bedroom
is the best
because i recently got some cool
flooring
and wallpaper have you seen it
no i haven't i saw it i saw it the first
time and there was just
loads of bears
when you walk outside over the water
it actually acts like you're walking the
water oh
yes it's really cool
oh i like a switch thank you
look at all of the bears
[Music]
oh gosh there's too many people yeah
it's quite a small room
okay i'm gonna leave this room i'm
getting claustrophobic yeah we do
the game is new with minor bugs still
yeah that's true alyssia but there are
so many um just quality of life stuff
that they could do
but also i i kind of get the feeling
that they want
you to spend a long time in this game so
they want you to go through like
endless dialogue and stuff just because
that's part of the animal crossing
experience in a weird way i don't know
i don't know if i'm just making excuses
forever whatever
amy you've gone silent again
hello oh there you go he's just not
talking to me
sorry
okay guys don't always have a lot to say
if we all
have ladders oh nice
let's go here this is my haunted
forest so just please be careful there
might be some spooky happenings around
here
oh my god there's blood blood
i'm getting flashbacks to last night
it's like bigfoot footprint camilla the
queen
and we got a queen following us thank
you for following wow
thank you i actually do have a um
silent hill uh save icon that i need to
put around
some somewhere um again
oh yeah i just changed that almost with
the outfit
uh and that's basically it really i mean
there's a couple of houses up here but
they're a little bit boring
so much going on up there right
[Laughter]
yeah basically well i mean we don't know
much about bigfoot
who's to say that he doesn't have two
right feet
[Music]
just one giant foot oh looks like that's
the blood
it's his other foot gosh
dragging of course
wait i love it there are gnomes up here
having a pic
like a campfire yeah that's just a house
but yeah you can go and check it out if
you want to
obviously so like i want to build a
narrative up here
where um they're both it's because it's
two people
and there's a river in between their
houses and i wanted to look like
they're kind of having a feud like they
hate each other
so i wanted to kind of like i don't know
like
the opposite ends of the spectrum like
maybe one's really like
girly and bright and colorful the other
ones are called black and dark or like
maybe there's
gnomes like along the edges and they're
all just looking at each other like that
like they're about to fight or something
i wanted
something like that but right now it's
just that
but i've got the basics ready for it yes
you've got time it just means next time
we do this all the other stuff to see
yeah exactly that's very true you get to
see the progression of my island
all right boys and girls
uh i'm gonna go back to the podcast area
you can make your way whenever you're
ready
and then i'll be opening presents
in real life as well as three oh
yay okay i'm excited
said also my name is alicio
it's it's latin but i go by ellie is it
ellie ely ellie i think ellie right
who can't pronounce my name feel free to
call me either
alicia ellie but let me know if i'm
butchering alicia and if i
am i'll call you ellie
unless i'm butchering ally as well and
then i'm screwed
to come up with the look all right
hopefully everyone can find this
okay yeah it looks like it okay
and now we've come wait wait wait
[Music]
do you reckon they can find us if you
can't find us
look for the map where presents go
oh did you pick them up no i didn't
actually
oh my god do you reckon when the game
crashed it like
[Music]
maybe oh it might have put all the
presents back in people's pockets
actually
yeah check your pockets guys okay
okay so i am going to
change into
my birthday suit for y'all
i'm actually not wearing any pants
[Music]
[Laughter]
kind of a bathing suit yeah
i actually i do have a design of like um
it looks like you're naked but it looks
like you're wearing like nipple tassels
oh wow i did that myself
why because why not i mean nudist
beaches it's a thing
um
okay so thank you for all your presents
i guess i'll put this wand away and i'll
start
opening i'll open them on the sofa
oh this is a family stream that's very
true luke
don't worry i'm not gonna get my actual
birthday suit for you guys you
are very privileged hey bill bill send
me my birthday suit haven't you bill
oh yes oh yes
[Laughter]
sometimes when i do a smack at bill he
like oh wait
i don't have my smack in mine
what haven't i been using
is everyone here
smack smack smack
okay sometimes when i smack it bill he
gets really freaked out at me and he
makes like this weird face
bill
bill
anyway too many people he's distracted
yeah he's like what is happening
okay i'm gonna sit down and open can i
open my presents now
oh i can't open them while i'm set down
that's sad okay i'll open them by the
cake
oh there's a present for you at the
shrine
oh i thought that was for god
what okay brb
have fun going to get that present
oh no wait how many presents have you
got
[Music]
sorry wonderful being
i'll put the peach back
there you go you need to put an offering
there i did
like indiana jones
uh elisa said if i'm being honest no one
can say my name it's straight mexican
name and
trying try saying ellie like eli
oh eli oh there's another
money tree up there i need to put it
into my secret garden okay
[Music]
okay i got them i got them
uh okay i'm gonna open them so first of
all i'm opening the orange one
okay let's see what this is
pixel shades oh no
i can't wear them now because i'm
wearing a i'm wearing a wand outfit
sorry guys wait
i'll put them on afterwards but thank
you
it looks it's okay and now i'm gonna
open
this one
open it was a cooler
it's a ukulele wait now i've got two
oh i can't place it i can't place it
because you guys are there but thank you
you know the more ukuleles the better we
need to make this like a ukulele island
and i wonder because it's cute because
like your neighbors actually when they
walk past
it they start to play it as well thank
you so much
guys now i'm going to open one of the
purple ones i've got two purple ones i'm
gonna open
this one let's see what this this one is
a kitchen island oh i haven't got enough
room for a kitchen yet but when i do and
i'm almost there i'm saving up
then i will upgrade thank you very much
yeah when i upgrade
i'm gonna drop this one so i'm gonna
open my other purple one
[Music]
a painting set ah
fun thank you guys
and i have i have a couple more i have
one more
from you guys and i've got a couple from
amy so i've got this
green one as well i don't know who's
from hughes so i hope you remember
a garbage can i've actually been looking
for a trash can
because it's so annoying when you can't
just like throw stuff away in the trash
thank you like i actually i actually
need that
thank you
um and i do have i have
some from amy so i have i have some that
she sent me this morning
a glass holder with a candle oh cute
you wanted that or did i
and i've got a throwback dino screen oh
crap yeah
we're supposed to put that in the
background up here oh well okay i can
use it for my museum
yes thank you that's what mine is nice
okay
[Music]
okay and now oh thanks guys
um now i'll open i guess i'll open my
main
my main present i'll open it on the sofa
someone's progressive also yeah i'm
okay so i am going to
open my actual present uh from amy
so if you guys i'm sure you guys are all
watching the stream as well
um but yeah if you want to have a little
look i'm going to make myself bigger so
amy gets to see this beautiful face
in more detail
you're like facing me
i love it um yeah i'm gonna
go and grab the present now sorry i
don't have a card for you
but i bought your birthday present in
january i hope you like the presents the
bigger one i've had for a very long time
forgot to give it to you
anyway i hope you have a good day can't
wait to celebrate with you when
lockdown's over
and then i hope you enjoy the random
things i found the glitter temporary
tattoos are meant for a night out but
you can decorate yourself for a wild
night in
instead
[Music]
okay should i open this one first uh
when you say this one what do you mean
because the
little video's a little bit late oh yeah
the little one is like the main one
yeah oh should i wait for the end on
this one then
it's me you do you yeah
perfect if it's the main one
okay
oh that's cute
you'll see it when when the stream
finally catches
the stream catches up when it catches up
oh it's a little dragon yeah it's
dragging my origami dragons that i make
oh my god
[Music]
i made you an orange one because you
like orange so these are the tattoos
love it maybe after the break i can like
put one on and then i can show you
that'll be cool i'm gonna put one on the
break i'm gonna put one on
yeah they're like glittery sticker
avo cool though no that was terrible
whoa this is a cool ass
card it's a really cool design
yeah there's like a candy strip that's
really cool
i love
um
i think i i think i know what this is
you might do
oh yeah okay you can kind of see it
through the bubble wrap
this was this one you were doing like
um was it inktober wasn't it
uh yeah halloween october whatever
yeah and i was like i love this one it's
so cool amy did this guys
now she sent it to me oh
i painted him for you as well because he
was just black and white before
he looks so cool amy
[Music]
yes
the final little one
[Music]
oh candy's trip it's from the same
person that did this
it's got a little fox on the box
it doesn't have anything to do with
boxes oh my god
oh my god amy this is so cool
oh
it's like a dead girl
oh wait no wrong camera it's a dead girl
guys it's a dead girl
i'm gonna wear her around my neck
oh that's so cool oh i'm so glad you
like it
yeah she's awesome
tom's like ooh cool i'm like yeah this
is a dead girl
yeah yeah yeah that's that's it
it really is it's like cute and
minimalist
but also a bit creepy i saw it i had to
buy it i was like that's just so you
where did you find this one where did
you find this candies trip i feel like i
need to know who this person is now
uh she's not on instagram i found her on
instagram because she's like an
artist that i follow but she does um
jewelry too
but she had a massive sale in january
because i was i really wanted to buy it
for you but it was a bit on the pricey
side and then
it fell into the sale i bought a
necklace for me too this like creepy
skull thing
yes we kind of map we kind of have
matching
cute i really like the box as well
it's got a little box on it i didn't
even think about that
yeah it's a really cute box i might just
use it for like little trinkets and
stuff
[Music]
dude
[Music]
there you go you did it yes
yes
yeah the box is really nice
[Music]
all right guys i think that is time for
a break
i'm gonna go put on my temporary tattoo
make a coffee
uh probably back in like what do you
think amy like
10 minutes yeah 10 minutes long enough
to
do stuff have a little break
if anyone wants to leave the island like
feel free to
totally fine um
luke's gonna do 10 minutes of break yes
get it all done
uh and then we'll come back and we'll
show
some music some music from uh luke who's
here on the island
i'll play some music and we'll do um
we'll do a q a so please do get some
questions ready for us to answer
when we get back if you have questions
specifically for amy or
i or any kind of like
deep questions because we were thinking
we could do it where you ask a question
and then we we spin the little wheel
and then if it lands on even then i have
to answer
if it lands on odd than amy has to
answer
so you could do something like that
or you could just ask us questions
[Music]
just a little bit extra
so get some questions ready if you want
to leave you can leave if you want to
stay
you're more than welcome to stay but we
will be back in
about 10 or so minutes time
so speak to you then yeah see you guys
uh guys can can we just can we just
witness this
why are people causing a ruckus
what no nuisance is
no i'm lying i mean i start i started
the fight okay guys i started to fight
it was me
i saw the fight i can't flavor on these
guys
oh my gosh
okay amy we're back look at this
fight play the fight
like let some people into your island
everyone's getting rowdy
oh my god
um i do have a new tattoo
oh look at these gums which one did you
get
what is it oh it's a b yeah
the b oh it's cute it's cute
yeah um
okay guys and girls
and everything in between um
it's music time
so please me please may we all gather
to listen to luke's song it is animal
crossing related
it's also jagman x related
you should all be very well known
a very well known what you should all
know what it is cool yeah i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna just gonna play the song
for you
stop talking none of this makes sense
i'm very excited
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i've been far too much for myself
[Music]
look at you guys it's so cute
[Music]
disagree would you only see
the nouns
strengthen that cray-cray
what's that
[Music]
[Music]
how good is that i don't even i don't
even know how luke did that
but i think that's amazing magic you're
a wizard luke
you're a wizard oh
thanks guys for wearing my jumper i
appreciate it it looks cute looks cute
on you both
lick it make it laugh
so that was a song that luke made for my
birthday it's kk slider's version
of sweater and it's amazing he did such
a good job
and he not only did he make that song
but he also
did the image that you see up on the
screen
did you see her dancing
it was very good dancing okay good
because i didn't know like whether it
was updating like when i was moving
yeah yeah oh good good
yeah he did that image yeah it's so
good it's done wow it's done so
wow a little ghost on your jumper i
can't
oh cute yeah so cute
thank you luke that was really cute to
wake up to yesterday
um thank you you're
very welcome i mean thank you all we're
saying is thank you for you so thank you
well how far we are so nice we're all
too nice
um i guess i said that i would play some
music now as well
so i will leave
um do you want the original version of
sweater or should i sing something else
i guess i should just do sweater
shouldn't i
that is like a fan favorite yes
everyone loves sweat let me turn up the
um
audio for the music again for the music
for the game and if you guys want to
you can play you can play the drums and
shine while i sing
[Music]
such a great stream it's really cool
though i love that i can have you guys
like in the stream as well
[Music]
what people say it's really uh
an animal crossing because just like
what sweater
your jumpers are nice
[Music]
so american
tumbo yeah it had the elbows out of tune
i need to change the strings online
because mine keeps going out too
very quickly you get a uh wait no have
you not got a quiller stream
yeah i do but it's been ages since i've
changed them so i think
well i mean they do go out of tune uh a
lot when you first change them as well
backup dancers hell yeah
everybody dance with me
wait i'll get i'll get here so you guys
oh i'm just so cute
you know what i might just like i might
what i might do is just like
put this into loads of little videos
after it's done
[Music]
please the yag dance troop oh this is so
cute i'm gonna move my webcam
[Music]
like a sweater
[Music]
yeah we got drama
to a surface that is
[Music]
[Music]
if
[Music]
[Music]
oh apparently i had to oh do the game
boring sorry
i could cry through the cracks
so could they close the muse straight
onto me but instead i
enjoy this view that ties
[Music]
please don't leave
[Music]
is
[Music]
cause i can't wait forever i'm not that
patient
i can't do anything to do your
comfy like a sweater but when the sun
comes out i won't be
yeah apparently the game audio was too
loud but that meant that everyone got to
hear the drums and stuff
so that was good you had backing vocals
as well courtesy of luke
yeah thank you for the vocals thank you
for the dancing
i love it i love it all
have you guys asked any questions in the
chat yet for later
thank you alicia welcome back and i'm
glad that your belly as well
it's a good feeling
luke my next on the night what
special guest uh luke's taking over
while you tune your guitar
he's called luke my next with guest star
me
nice nice sass cream in the house what
are you guys going to do together
[Music]
um well i'm just waiting for
it he's there oh he's talking about you
he says
oh we're gonna tell jokes okay
i guess you'll be the boys
[Music]
yeah luke says he's gonna start so he
says knock knock
who's there
okay i can't do the typing
[Music]
oh i know i'll do this he says it's a
chicken
chicken chicken whoa
[Music]
a chicken who wants cereal
do you have any no
that was that was the best yay luke
knock knock jokes um
knock knock
uh orange
orange orange you glad
i didn't tell another chicken joke
was that or just the lead up to that
joke
uh no don't diss our comedy duo
no i'm not disney i'm just i'm asking a
question
we're just was just trying it this is
like a test tonight when we try out our
jokes
a safe place
okay if you guys have been laughing
emoji that would be great
that would really boost our spirits yeah
they just
stood there like
and why did the chicken cross the road i
don't know i'm not listening anymore
it's again
[Music]
i laughed
yeah this is just i'm very excited about
myself
i
[Music]
[Applause]
okay i'm gonna leave because luke
doesn't like me being duo
oh no it doesn't look like this very
well
oh no
that was a bad joke
it's hard stuff you don't do a lot of
the pasta yeah
no
thank you alyssia hey we got lip music
session going oh
okay i'll play my euclidean vibe with
y'all
do it sounds good everyone get their
musical instruments out
have some music music session
and i've got mine talking about some
cereal
i think luke's hungry yeah i think
luke's hungry too
oh that's why my curtains fell down well
keratin
my scarf that i use the curtains fell
right down up
should be slightly better lighting now
no no oh it looks like another joke
he says what do you get if you cross a
llama and amy
what do you get
oh no amy riding a lava
wow i thought he was gonna call me lady
but no
just oh what is
nice about it
okay i'm gonna sing now
sorry uh
[Music]
that's the thing okay
hopefully some game music is
okay
[Music]
thanks luke for the introduction i
appreciate it
[Music]
everything you once hates
does it match up to what you
saw
[Music]
go
[Music]
the late nights
you pushed away what could
[Music]
um
[Music]
i don't have much money but
i have something worth
so much more a future to cross
if your hand will unplug
don't i deserved
[Music]
and everything we wanted
i know it has changed from before
[Music]
a vision of a life we can't afford
we'll waste all our money on
[Music]
until we're over
don't we deserve
[Music]
it
[Music]
did you see his every moment
was it your choice you made
to replace those who cared
[Music]
judgment keeps us staying
to a place our
[Music]
something far more
[Music]
is that an original yeah yeah oh my god
i love it
oh thank you yes so so good people
asking if it was an original in the chat
yes yes it's an original song
thank you thank you when are you
releasing that one i don't know
i don't know i don't know i need to
practice it more and then i'll probably
record it and upload it
uh like an acoustic version and then jb
and i
are going to work on a produced version
yes i love it when you and jamie work
with music
well jamie and i have been working on
another song actually
[Applause]
guitar related in the future no not good
now
but i mean he puts guitar to them all
anyway so but
maybe in the future um but well maybe
later on i can give you guys a little
teaser if jamie doesn't mind
jamie can let us know in the chat just
like a little
a little 30 second clip maybe a little
minute
no not a minute 30 seconds
what was that song called that you just
saw
[Applause]
you named it yet not really i mean i'm
guessing deserve like
you deserve more or we deserve more or
something
because it's supposed to be kind of like
a play off of like all those stupid
adverts where they're like
you're worth it but it's just like
they're trying to make money right
so it's like yeah in that it's like
you'd tell us that we deserve
more by saying you deserve more so you
should buy this
but it's like no we deserve more than
that like
does that make sense yeah it's very cool
jarvis
oh cosmo though i love cosmere
yeah um
so yeah i guess uh what's the next thing
oh i know what the next thing is
it's q a time [ __ ]
let's answer your questions okay
everyone
if you start to write your questions in
the chat
we can answer them oh my gosh look i've
got like my little cactus clan
i love this i don't i didn't get it wait
i thought i got it but i did it
oh that's why i left because i thought
oh wait i do
yay and eli said he was chilling with
his
uh his ukulele if i had to switch to my
guitar to get the same tone
nice nice little play along
oh my god look at us look at this little
clan i want to take a picture
this is so cute i'm gonna take a picture
of us all
oh wait put my stupid fish wand away
one second put this away
what nonsense
oh we look adorable
i love it
we look so cute i love this so
much
i mean buttercup i know i look more like
um
and i'd probably act more like blossom
though
but i do like buttercup when i was a kid
i was like buttercup is badass
she's so cool but yeah i like
was it bubbles bubbles yeah that's the
blonde yeah she's my favorite
she's my favorite she's so cute cutie
i love it so much it's a good jumper it
is so good
um we do have more questions um are you
on the chat amy
yes um um
wait is it alicio how are we wait
eli eli i don't eli how long have you
been singing for
[Music]
[Laughter]
i've been singing ever since i was a kid
um
my mom's got a picture of me like as a
little baby next to the radio singing
apparently i just never stopped singing
so i don't know but like
um if you mean professionally or like
actually trying i guess
in primary school because i used to go
to guides and then we used to sing in
theater
and then i used to sing music lessons
my music teacher in primary school
actually she took me to like
a music college or something for a day
for me to get professional lessons yeah
but then my mom couldn't afford to carry
on paying for them
but it was cool yeah yeah that's cool
that you got
[Music]
luke says mojo jojo is the best part of
girl
uh other animals
[Music]
buttercup is the pink one
yeah the pink one with blonde hair yes
no isn't it oh sorry buttercup sorry i
thought it said um bubbles
no buttercup is this one this is
buttercup
the green one with black short hair
and green eyes and green top
she's the one that's all like hard like
bad ass
moody yes moody grumpy
but like i say i'm more like blossom
blossom is the leader tells people what
to do
all the time
oh did you attend any extra activities
during school
that was from nantes
um
i mean i did a lot in primary school i
think i did what did i do i did
dance for a while oh yeah i've shown you
the pictures haven't i
of me and my like dance outfit
little competitions yeah in my little
leotard there's a dance for quite a
while
and i got a few awards for that nothing
major just like little
like local star like second and third
place it used to be freestyle dancing
and then theater so that's like
it was always musical theater um
i was baby june uh
guides uh
you died guides yeah brownies and guides
i died a lot i died
alongside school um i always wanted to
go to brownies i never did though why
it was pretty fun it wasn't too bad it
got kind of boring by the end
i think brownies was better than guides
i think because i moved sometimes that
wasn't done
oh yeah yeah of course of course
oh and i went trampolining trampolining
was fun
did you do anything me um
i did piano lessons
[Music]
because i could piano
i think i did gymnastics for a little
bit as well
oh just i wanted to be a gymnast because
they were like the coolest people
yeah but again i moved and then there
wasn't
any gymnastics
[Music]
oh luke wants us to spin the wheel for
his question
which is what is something
you hate that everyone else likes
okay so i'm on even you're on odd
okay
oh oh yeah do you want to stop it
wait look you asked the question luke
you stop it
you just go up and press it
[Music]
[Laughter]
one it's you you have to answer oh
wait so what is something i hate that
everyone else likes
yeah oh
um like sauces like ketchup
mustard things like that i don't eat
sauces i'm saucy enough
what i tell people so i don't like
sauces
none of that that's it i like curry
sauce
yeah you don't like tomato ketchup i
think that's a very good one
like everyone loves tomato ketchup and
you hate it i don't like tomatoes
and you're not that keen on on tomatoey
like if a pizza if pizzas
if the pizza is too tomatoey
yes if it's got loads of cheese on i can
still eat pizza but if it's too
much sauce i can't just
such a saucy fact
if anyone has any more questions like
that we can spin the wheel for like if
it's like a
truth kind of question
that was a good question i like that uh
[Music]
ellie smokes says what's your goal for
the future playing music for a living
full-time streamer video
game designer honestly my
goal is so silly it's like everything
everything that i ever i don't really
know i
i'd love to just like have a little
company where we just make things that
we're really passionate about and i just
get to work with people who are super
passionate about things
i wanna i wanna make games though i
don't wanna stop making games games is
my main thing
and i think if you make a game there's
so many things that go into a game that
will also provide me what i want to do
in all my other aspects of my hobbies
so for instance i like singing games
need music
like i like games need
to be coded like i like
uh i like drawing not very good but i
like drawing games need to be drawn for
um other things
i like making videos and talking to
people online and doing social media
games need social media around them
you know games need to be live stream
games need to be hyped up like games
need trailers
games need in-game cinematics in-game
cut scenes
so basically probably games um which
i'm already in so it's cool it's cool
[Music]
uh maria pizza's like uh you can't talk
trash about pizza
sorry very sorry wait
i've got a good thing for this
we apologize
i'm so sorry
eli smokes is my twitch account so eli
is fine
ah okay cool cool cool
[Music]
there's another question oh yeah what's
the question
uh it's from some millennic
and what did you want to become when you
were a child i feel like you
oh this should be a spin the wheel one
uh maria
oh you're sad no
that was like mario and then i thought
she's like
[Laughter]
do you want to spin the wheel
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay who wants to stop it
uh oh i
don't know okay stop it
oh my god is it eight it's it's
definitely
okay thank you thank you lovely
assistant no it's eight
look at the live stream it's the
replication
there's replication issues in the game
where it's not it's just what will
happen because
obviously every client will see
something is slightly different uh what
was that question though because
i got distracted was the bit what what
did you want to be when you were younger
it was someone lanavik's question wasn't
it
yeah was that the question uh let's go
back
[Music]
oh yes what did you want yeah yeah
that's true what did you want to become
when you were a child
uh so i guess it was eight so that would
be me right
even i've forgotten but yeah you
so um
i wanted to be a singer i want to be a
famous singer
there's actually just this one thing i
just wanted to sing
cool
that was like when i was very young
though
uh oh
what
looks like someone's on the way here
it's sammy do we have anyone new coming
or is this just for you guys it takes so
long
we we had the person with the halo i
haven't seen them before oh
are they new yeah i forgot to look at
their name
uh mantas has got a good question
he says you don't talk about movies or
series that often
do you like horror or is another genre
more younger more appealing
or do you have a favorite movie i like
horror but i don't like watching horror
on my own
because i do get very scared just like
it's so annoying because i love
horrified i do get very scared
it's like i don't like that
yeah so i love watching horror with
friends
um and i don't like horror so that's
what we would
yeah that's what our sleepovers would be
but no
wait what was the question like what
movies do i like what series do i like
uh yeah or do you have like
do you like other stuff like not horror
oh looks like we're giving to you
i love studio ghibli
i'm re-watching all their films now as
well as ones i haven't seen
i love like the japanese
kind of view on the world
with the nature spirits and
kind of how human beings should live in
harmony with
nature and all of its like magical
spirits and stuff
i love all that stuff so studio ghibli
is great
um what i mean
i i watch some like anime i guess would
that
would would a gretsuko be classed as
anime
like cartoony things uh i like
documentaries about real things
um i didn't really know what to say
you liked castle rock because i watched
sex you went on about it for asia
did i did i
this is stephen king i don't think i've
watched that one
did i yeah you have castle rock you have
definitely
okay because you went on and on and on
about it
apparently i yeah i mean
i am a very obsessive person so if i get
into something i'll obsess
over it for a while and then i'll find a
new obsession i could apparently just
completely forget
yeah she's like what what is that i just
removed that
new memory yeah i haven't been watching
watch tv though recently i've been
watching mainly critical role which is
like dungeons and dragons
and then the studio ghibli films because
they make me feel good
yeah yeah like right now tiger
documentary hasn't really
appealed to me yeah i think like with
this situation going on i just want
like feel good stuff i don't really want
anything too hard
what's this what's your name again
hi welcome welcome to the island
did you sneeze
welcome to the island welcome wait
hello who are we missing
[Music]
uh where's luke he's there
hi behind the tree uh
no this is us this is all of us this is
that's an extra
plus an extra hey pam
thank you for coming you can take a look
around if you want
or you can stick with us it's totally up
to you
totally up to you
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's so cool oh look
maria talking to marcel
is he wearing face paint
he's mine he's a mom dog oh
dog okay
do we have any more any for the wheel
okay we'll do um
[Music]
we'll answer should we answer it 196's
question
any upcoming games you're looking
forward to
yeah i mean
just answer that oh okay
[Music]
any upcoming games you're looking
forward to
me yeah
no i don't play a lot of games animal
crossing was like
the pinnacle of what i wanted
so just happy living
it's a good question
so i'm trying to get back to my normal
outfit so i can put my jumper on
um i actually don't
know i mean that i watched the xbox
um oh yeah so i watched the xbox
gameplay
thing which none of it was gameplay but
you know that's been talked about too
much
now um but that
was that game with that medium medium i
think it was
um the people who made layers of fear
and blair witch they're working on
another horror game
i think they they understand horror like
they're
they're interesting they they get
psychological horror it's not just sort
of jump scares and stuff
and they're actually working with the
guy who did the sound design
um for silent hill the original silent
hills
oh cool okay yeah so um
hope someone's leaving
[Music]
bye so yeah that should be really
interesting
i'm very much looking forward to that
and also
i thank you for coming palm i don't know
if
they were actually oh they must have
been in the chat
um i was gonna say something else um
hal blade two i'm looking forward to
that i don't
well whenever we hear more about that
and they're working on another project
which is supposed to be like a horror
one
so obviously i'm excited for that from
ninja theory
i think that's the main ones and then i
know that hideo kojima is working on a
horror game now
so i'm looking forward to that
interested
oh apparently the guy who made
apparently someone behind siren blood
curse like the siren games
he's working on a new horror game but
this was a long time ago that i heard
oh and i want to hear more about the
harry potter open world game
we need to hear more about that like
when are we going to hear more about
that we had the leak that was like two
years ago now or something
i don't know when that's going to come
out and then apparently there's
there's a new bioshock huh what platform
will that be on though
i guess you don't know i think pc i
don't know really
but yeah it was just the the um
oh no wait you guys all get kicked
no
the guy with the beard looks really cool
so melanovic is that you
or are they talking to luke you're
talking to one of them so milan of it
wait do you have a beer yeah you do some
atlanta beak
look up from your phone double and a
week look up from your phone
look up from your phones
it looks like this is one year's group
he doesn't care he's too cool for you he
doesn't care
jack d w frost he's too cool
his beard knows it's a wig
his beard is too full too cold for this
world
he's like he's probably like going to
the toilet or something
he's back
you're big someone gave you a compliment
on your beard
gave me a compliment wait it was jack d
w frost gave you a compliment on your
beard
and you didn't say nothing because
you're too
cool to say thank you
[Laughter]
music horror story and still work that's
why
everything takes me a long time to do
i usually put it all on my calendar and
try and do at least an hour's work after
work every day
and then i try and do work every other
weekend but i burn out hard
when i burn out i've burned out hard aim
you know i do
yeah i don't know exactly i'll get so
tired and i literally cannot work
anymore so that's
the bad thing about working yourself too
hard but
workaholic guys it's just bound to have
it
you just should not work it's easy
yeah luke's doing a good job of that
[Music]
she don't work just going all the way
like
thank you so much for joining us i'm
going to say goodbye to everyone that i
can see
in the chat now um you guys have made
today real cool
thank you so much not just for today but
also yesterday and thursday
this has been honestly honestly one of
the best birthdays
like it actually has even though i
haven't been with you guys no it's been
so good because
yeah you surprised me katie surprised me
i know katie wants us all to hang out on
a group chat my mom can't wait to hang
out and
we're gonna skype tomorrow and my
stepbrother
sent me a video of my niece singing me
happy birthday
and like and like annie got me harleen
and then like yeah just the community
gave me this
amazing surprise i had no freaking idea
and now i can live stream animal
crossing
and put back
on my birthday outfit
the last time i get to wear my birthday
girl outfit
yo i'm wearing suspenders
[Music]
it would just be in the cactus i love it
when you do this because it looks like
you're putting your leg up like
that
okay i wonder if i can take a picture
like this
is
can i like turn the camera around no i
can't well i want to get
i think tom's back just for the end
thank you for joining for the yes yes
wait me and luca are getting our thighs
out around you one second
there you go oh okay you're gonna take a
picture of that
yeah thanks thanks for that appreciate
[Music]
it
i'm just loving life right now yeah
you're like away
um
no i've had a really good day and thank
you so much for everyone that
did listen and come to the island ah
yeah
yeah and uh have a great weekend guys
for those of you that are in the island
i'll keep it open
um if um i'm doing
something and then my switch goes to
sleep then you'll probably be kicked
but just know i didn't do it on purpose
but you can hang out for as long as you
can so feel free to hang out if you want
to
uh feel free to send me like a friend
request as well i'll accept them and you
can pop over some other time if i've
ever got
my gates open again okay
oh whoa all right
so this is the awkward goodbye face
everyone say goodbye
bye